for more on the situation at our
southern border we're joined by former
acting dhs secretary and heritage
foundation visiting fellow
chad wolfe mr secretary thank you for
taking time
on a saturday i want to you just heard
bill millusion's
report about the criminals being
apprehended
the chief in the del rio
sector chief austin scaro tweeted
yesterday
that there are 438 criminal migrants
that they've apprehended just in that
sector in del rio
alone of which 77 are sex offenders
seven convicted murders that's just one
sector
mr secretary how concerned are you that
with these overwhelming numbers we
haven't seen
in two decades is letting in an unknown
amount of
criminals well it's absolutely a concern
obviously we have a humanitarian crisis
going on at that border but
within that humanitarian crisis is also
a security crisis so
the more and more that law enforcement
is not on the line
doing their national security mission
and they're in border patrol stations
caring for these migrants these family
units and these miners
the less agents that we have on the line
looking for these criminals and stopping
that illegal flow so there's certainly a
security
aspect here that's very very concerning
when you we know from
experience going back to 2019 and even
earlier
we know when you have a large number of
individuals coming to the border
every single day and night we know that
bad people will try to hide themselves
within that flow
and so i'm glad to hear that border
patrol is able to identify some of these
folks
but there's a large number of folks
every single day um over
a thousand i would say closer to 2000
that we what are what we call got aways
uh these are individuals that
uh are never encountered by border
patrol and so that's what concerns me
because you don't know if those are
family units
you don't know if those are ms-13
members and you don't know if they're
actually uh far dangerous terrorists and
others
so there's certainly a security aspect
to that border
uh that is is uh certainly a concern
during this humanitarian crisis well
sure
sure it is and as our viewers are
looking that's our drone footage over
the penidus texas area in the rgb sector
and they go right through that
uh wall opening and they go to the farm
to market road over to highway 2
straight up north and all over the
country you talk about the guidaways but
let's talk about
the number released we're now hearing
more than 61
000 migrants have been released into
the united states since february
compared to 364
to trump's president trump's last year
that
is a startling number your reaction it
absolutely is a storytelling number and
it's a direct result
of the policies that this administration
has put in place over the last
four months if you're a minor you're
going to get released into the
united states if you're a family unit
you are likely going to be released into
the united states so what does that do
that incentivizes you to grab a child
and try to come across that border and
claim that you're a family unit because
you know
that you will be released into the
interior of the united states and that's
your goal at the end of the day
that's your goal and that's what this
administration is facilitating and then
once you do get here you know that you
will not be removed because again
this administration has put the
handcuffs on ice
law enforcement agents they can now not
remove individuals
that again have no legal right to be
here unless you're a serious
aggravated felon or you're a terrorist
exactly
and i want to hit that with you before
we run out of time we've only got about
a minute left
mr secretary but we have seen of course
president biden rejecting the abolish
ice calls
early on politically but it seems that
many of the things from
the number of deportations down 60 to
the really taking away the enforcement
tools for ice that they've done just
that abolish them
absolutely i think the administration's
just paying lip service to
we're not going to abolish ice but
everything that they have done the
policies that we put in place
they're now going back on private
detention facilities so they're trying
to reduce the number of detention
facilities out there
every single policy that they have done
is to tear down
isis ability to do their job at the end
of the day so instead of congress
changing the law
which they won't do because they don't
have a consensus
this administration is trying to do it
through executive order and through
policy and it's wrong
it's dangerous and we're not protecting
our communities like we should
former dhs acting secretary chad wolf mr
secretary thank you for taking time
thank you